welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session on
pioneering our understanding of the
human brain my name is dr. rocha
Nakashima
and I'm a computational scientist and
the clinical scientist by training my
research interests address information
processing and coding in neural circuits
with translational applications tumor
psychiatric and neurological disorders
today I will be talking to you about
deep brain stimulation opportunities and
ethical dilemmas we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
by laberd's we'd like to extend our
special thanks to the brain initiative
program directors in particular dr.
James knack for their efforts in
organization before I began I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting questions
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box I'll be
responding to questions by email
following my presentation my
presentation is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now let's jump right in
neurological disorders affect as many as
1 billion people worldwide nearly 45
million adults suffered from mental
illness in 2016 which is about 18% of
the u.s. population that costs about 100
billion dollars in lost productivity
brain disorders are placing a staggering
multifactorial burden on society
worldwide so we are really ethically
compelled to carefully consider and
address these issues
there are various treatment options that
are being explored and developed
continually behavioral pharmacological
and surgical the surgical options come
in when the other options are no longer
really viable for the patient typically
the surgical options have been ablation
orally
which are irreversible but now there's a
new neuro technology deep brain
stimulation or DBS which can be applied
to those patients who are medically
refractory now we've been hearing a lot
about DBS in the news it's been called
brain hacking it's been given a very
large growth in the global market
there's these amazing surgeries that are
being reported and that the demand is
growing in the field of neurology and
then we're talking about these like
miraculous recoveries for patients who
have Parkinson's and since that was so
effective and people started extending
it to psychiatric indications like
depression and OCD autism etc and it's
even been extended now past that to
disorders like stroke and now even the
US based program is involved so what is
DBS it's a revolutionary new therapy in
which a subcutaneously implanted pulse
generation generator sends continuous
high-frequency stimulation to deep
structures in the brain via chronically
implanted electrodes the deep brain
stimulation device has often been called
a brain pacemaker and it looks like this
it's made of a lead wire with electrodes
the lead wires are being pointed to by
the blue arrows and the electrodes are
circled in red there's an extension wire
to which they're connected and that's
connected to the implantable pulse
generator which then will deliver the
electrical pulses that will go to the
deep targets in the brain that are
specific for whatever the disorder is
the goal of DBS is to rebalance or
modulate the neural circuits
sufficiently to shift the patient into
their best functional state the
mechanism of action of DBS is suggested
to provide therapeutic relief of
refractory symptoms via the modulation
of dysregulated networks but in fact
we don't really understand the
mechanisms or the principles of DBS yet
which actually matches our neurological
disorders we also don't really know how
these disorders what the dysfunction is
that underlies these disorders we have
some ideas but those also have not been
fully determined yet but we do think
that they have to do with these central
circuits that involve the cortex the
basal ganglia and the thalamus and this
is a circuit that goes around in a loop
and what's really important is to keep a
good balance between those pathways that
are in that lumen
so these pathways are signaling each
other through synchronized oscillatory
activity at different frequencies and
it's really sensitive the circuit to
those frequencies and it's thought that
a change in these oscillatory frequency
might be responsible for the disruption
for the change in the behavior that is
reflecting a disruption in the
synchronous activity now DBS has been
approved for Parkinson's essential
tremor and dystonia these were the
original ones for which DBS was approved
and motor disorders and psychiatric
disorders make up neuropsychiatric
disorders and the motor dispersion of
the first ones to be approved and then
it was extended to obsessive compulsive
disorder in the psychiatric psychiatric
disorders category and it's being used
off-label or has been used off-label for
Tourette's syndrome addiction and also
autism and other disorders so we're
going to concentrate today on Tourette's
syndrome
what is Tourette syndrome juditha
Tourette's syndrome is classified by its
symptoms it is classified through
childhood onset multiple the presence of
multiple motor tics and at least one
fawning tic and all of these have to be
persistent for at least a year and in
the absence of some other
medical issue or pharmaceutical
involvement
so using DBS we'd like to be able to
take the opportunity to understand
perhaps the pathophysiology underlying
Tourette's syndrome and maybe see if
there's a role for oscillations and
ultimately see if we might be able to
find a biomarker that would help us
therapeutically so in our lab back in
Florida what we did was use this mirror
paste device which has these electrodes
now circled in red into deep target and
then we implanted this impulse generator
in the cranium the study design was for
five subjects to her treatment
refractory with steel the Lateran
syndrome we did chronic recordings using
the nervous system so these recordings
occurred over time while the patient was
implanted and moving around freely and
behaving the implants are in the central
media nucleus of the thalamus recorded
local field potentials and we then used
the clinical metric the yellow global
tic severity scale or the Y GTS s to
assess symptomatology and what we found
was that there was that there were
clinical benefits correlated with an
increase in the gamma man power
so the oscillatory frequency that we
found was relevant for Tourette Syndrome
and we found one that was was in fact
gamma and what we ended up finding was
that there was a hypo synchrony that was
correlated with the pathophysiology so
on the left you can see our five
patients and the various frequencies
that were recorded and on the right you
can see those same five patients after
six months and you can see that the
responders are the ones in the center
will have this spike in the gala
frequency
range so an increase in gamma was
correlated with a decrease in
symptomatology as reflected on the yg
TSS and when we looked at the other
frequencies we did not see a correlation
with symptomatology which which you can
also see here so we found that there was
an increase in thalamic gamma
synchronization that correlated with an
decrease in symptomatology there was a
clinical correlation between gamma
oscillations and the symptomatology as I
said and that other oscillatory
frequencies did not directly correlate
with clinical benefit the findings
derived from this research have offered
important insights into tick Genesis and
tick expression because up until then we
really didn't have any understanding of
what was underlying to Genesis and now
we can correlate that with a hypo
synchronization of gamma oscillations in
the CM thalamus and that impacts patient
care and of course patient quality of
life when we're able to effectively
apply that in deep brain stimulation
therapy so we could modulate the gamma
band activity in long-term deep brain
stimulation of the central media nucleus
of the thalamus and use that to mitigate
a pathophysiology that's associated with
Tourette's syndrome and that gap event
oscillations couldn't in fact serve as a
biomarker for Tourette's syndrome and
could be useful in online neurosurgical
procedure to help guide the neuro
surgeon to the optimized target location
and as well in closed loop stimulation
now
we wanted even though we have a lot of
advantages and opportunities that we
gained from using the brain stimulation
we also have to consider the ethics so
there's two things to consider when
we're doing ethical considerations one
is deep brain stimulation itself and
what's associated with that and the
other is your blood rehearsal so what do
I mean by that well with deep brain
stimulation
of course there's a risk of surgery and
all the risks that are associated with
having brain surgery including
hemorrhages etc there can be or
epileptic seizures we also have to
consider that we do not understand the
mechanism of action when stimulation and
while it's touted as being reversible
unlike our other ablation therapy and
lesion there be what we don't really
know is what how much plasticity is
involved when we do provide deep brain
stimulation and now it's been suggested
that we do in fact see some plasticity
so that's also debated so the
reversibility of is debated and of
course there are the side effects that
come from the specific target and the
stimulation parameters that are applied
so we can have various side effects that
come actually from the deep brain
stimulation in the therapeutic stage
itself now for the la Tourette syndrome
we have to consider patient selection
age is a very important topic here and
also the clinical presentation we want
to look at target selection because
target selection is also a hotly debated
issue in deep brain stimulation therapy
which extends across all the
neurological disorders to which its
applied Parkinson's Tourette's OCD etc
finding the optimal deep target in the
brain and the optimal region of that
target as well and each of those will
give a specific outcome and for Tourette
Syndrome we also want to look at the
natural history which I'll discuss with
you in a minute and we have considered
it but it's rarely shown in its pure
profile and often is found comorbid with
other disorders especially
obsessive-compulsive disorder and ADHD
so here we can see that in a study that
has looked at the baseline values in
very large abs cohorts that that the
onset the age of onset for Tourette's
was approximately seven point eight
years but the diagnosis occurred at
twelve point three years and then the
surgery occurred at two point twenty
nine years and one of the things that
was important to consider as I mentioned
is the comorbidities and the
comorbidities for treads are often would
drive the patient to actually seek
medical care so it's the expression of
the symptoms of those comorbidities that
are really important and provide a
complex profile for the patient and that
also effect what we see here as the
various targets that are available for
the application of DES so one of the
most compelling ethical issues here is
at what age do we perform DBS on a
patient as you saw the average age was
29 even though the onset age was 7 and
the diagnosis was 12 well this is
relevant when we look at the natural
history of Tourette's syndrome here on
the x-axis we look at the age of the
patient and on the y-axis we can see the
relative tic severity and if you look
you will see that the tic severity is
peaking just pre-pubertal II now that's
a very sensitive time psychologically
and physiologically for people for
children these are sensitive periods in
which a lot of changes are occurring and
so you really want to ask yourself do
you want to interfere at that point with
the child's development if you're going
to have a spontaneous resolution of the
symptoms do you really want to interfere
with the child and do brain surgery this
is very important question to ask
normally it would just jump to the
conclusion and say well I shouldn't
interfere because the there
good chance that the symptoms were
resolved spontaneously but let me remind
you that ticks can present themselves in
various ways and including self
injurious behavior which can be very
damaging but not withstanding that when
you see someone who's barking and
yelping and jumping up and down you
would imagine that they are mentally
incompetent which is not the case for
Tourette's patients in fact they are
completely competent and are would like
to engage as just possible in normal
activity but that becomes really
confounded by the ticks and also by
these various comorbidities that can
occur with juvenile Tourette's syndrome
and so especially in severe cases where
you have things like self injurious
behavior you can really have a lot of
consequences to these symptoms including
physical injury emotional distress you
can have obstruction of Education
because the children have a hard time
attending school whether it's for
concentration or because the other kids
are giving them a hard time
and you also have the psychosocial
impairment that goes with that so you
can do irreparable harm by the time you
get to young adulthood because of all
these other issues that occur so why
would you consider DBS for juveniles
well you would want it emotional
problems that can occur and prevent them
you certainly want to give the best
chance for normal social development to
the child and of course an academic
development that is unimpeded and these
children because of these issues can
develop low self-esteem and finally mood
or anxiety disorders and so these are
very serious problems that absolutely
affect their development well why
wouldn't you want to consider DBS for
juveniles because you're implanting a
device in a developing brain that as we
said
we don't know exactly how it works and
we're not sure of the plasticity issues
etc we have limited knowledge of the
long-term effects these have not been
studied well and certainly not in
juveniles for who have gotten DBS the
devices are very quickly evolving this
is new neuro technology and continually
changing and so you want to be
considered of that as well and there
might be a competing desire for the
implant you don't know if the child
really wants it or if they're competent
to say they do and what if by the time
they're 18 they don't now you really
have an issue about having what another
brain surgery to remove the device and
you know financial burden for doing it
there's a lot of issues that are then
correlated with that and finally when we
consider the Natural History as we said
well there's a really good chance that
there's going to be a spontaneous
resolution so do we want to interfere
with the developing brain by doing brain
surgery and all the risks that are
associated with brain surgery for the
juvenile so what's the bottom line well
really need to sit and think about the
risks versus the benefits and these have
to really be tailored to each individual
patient and considered by a group there
has to be a team that is involved and
there has to be a team that's involved
in the decision-making and it has to be
very carefully considered and it would
be very beneficial to have a neuro
ethicist on that team to help guide the
team through all these different issues
that can come up and are really quite
intricate I'd like to thank the team in
Florida that we did the work together
for the data that I showed you
previously and finally I'd like to thank
you very much for your attendance and as
a reminder I'd like to let you know that
if you have any questions about
presentation and please go ahead and
send them in and I will answer you by
email stay tuned for a next track
neuroethics where we will hear from our
top experts on the ethics of using new
neuro technologies and the impacts of
our advancements to ensure these
objectives continue with best practices
hope to see you there